this rule is one of my favorites it's
the golden rule
hopefully you learned this in elementary
school you want to have compassion
to everyone you're communicating with on
social or anywhere
else and remember that they're humans
just like you maybe they
you know got into a car accident the
other day or maybe
their daughter is giving them a hard
time about
doing homework or maybe their boss is
you know
driving them up a wall people have lives
and you're not the only thing in it and
when you go at them
in your social marketing with empathy
with sympathy
you give them permission to be
themselves and then you make that line
between
trustworthiness tighter stronger and of
course faster you just get there quicker
the sale goes quicker
so you want to put yourself in someone's
shoes whenever possible
this is why that reading aloud tip is so
important so you can
really feel and hear how you sound to
others and think about
really what you want to be understood
what's your
what's your objective on the other end
and we're going to touch on that um
shortly as well
but i think about this like when again
whether i'm asking my husband to
wash the dishes or i'm asking a team
member to
do a task that they've forgotten about
or if i'm on social and i'm trying to
get you to come to my webinar
i'm trying to think about who are the
people that are reading it what's going
to
turn them on what's going to be their
the spark that lights them up that makes
them
do this thing i want them to do right
and what's the what's the emotion and
the value
behind that what's the win for them
right and how can i communicate that
so one really super easy way to do that
is to think about time zones
so what we find is that a lot of people
can't do math
i was a fiction writing major i can't do
math either and
um just the simple act of giving people
more time zones to choose from
is a huge way to just say like i get it
you know
i want to be helpful to you by the way
all the tips we just talked about are
here as well
do you know the 56 the number actual
magic words you can hear me saying this
i got the magic hat in there
drive sales word's so powerful the the
united nations consults this guy so i'm
now giving him some authority so you
guys wanna
why would you bother listening to this
name that you don't even know well
because the
united nations pays him to tell them
what to do that's kind of
kind of awesome and then all the other
little tricks that i talked about
earlier